[Music]
today is officially the first day of
summer congratulations
yeah
so
in honor of this i'll be hosting the
rest of the show wearing short shorts
not just short shorts daisy dukes
andy what are you gonna be wearing i've
already started chafing
this is gonna be terrible the minute you
said it yeah exactly what else is going
on uh of course we've got a presidential
race going on right now the obama
campaign did you hear this they've
unveiled a new ad designed to target
hispanics
get the hispanic voter yeah
yeah
it's basically the president saying yo
soy el hombre who killed osama bin laden
couldn't they translate the whole
sentence no
they understand
just run with
that none of you saw this but last night
on the premiere of her new reality show
bristol palin do you see bristol pounds
reality show
i didn't think so last night
on the premiere of a new reality show
bristol palin confronted a man in a bar
and demanded to know why he hates her
mother
yeah
in response john mccain said leave me
alone i'm having a drink
[Applause]
there's a new weapon in the war on
terror this is very cool i love these
technological advances that the military
comes up with it's being reported this
is true that the united states military
has created tiny drones the size and
shape of insects
seriously
yeah these tiny drones don't kill
anybody but they can totally ruin al
qaeda's annual summer picnic
he's ruining everything
cancel the three-legged race
potato salad's ruined
hillary clinton in the news hillary
clinton apparently has been traveling
more than any other secretary of state
she travels constantly next week someone
counted up hillary clinton will travel
to her 100th country
100th country
yeah
yeah and in each country upon landing
her first question is have you seen my
husband
yay
crazy story yesterday it was reported
that the u.s navy recovered 19 tons of
marijuana that had been dumped into the
ocean
19 tons of marijuana yeah
yeah then two hours later the united
states navy invaded taco bell
[Applause]
we will liberate that enchanto
[Laughter]
what's the thing that's really popular
now everyone loves the tacos oh that
taco loco dorito thingy yeah yeah
i swear to god that thing is so any time
we mention it on the show the loco
dorito is that what it is something
anytime do we know what it is does
anyone please let's see
i love my audience knows exactly what it
is
you idiots
what is it
burrito locos taco one of you at a time
this is a bad session of parliament
which is the taco bell snack
i love too my fans they're angry that i
don't know i'm right it's the local taco
supreme
anyway it's that thing's gonna bring
this country together it certainly is
it's one thing we can all agree on
anytime anybody talks guys still talking
still trying to correct me say it sir
just you alone say it what is it tacos
will bring america together oh that's
not i was looking for the name of the
product
this is what happens when i bring every
oh i don't know
i think his insulin pump is
malfunctioning yeah
[Laughter]
hey summer olympics almost here gang
what about that huh
we're getting ready yeah here's the
latest big story today olympic officials
are considering banning women athletes
who are considered too masculine
yeah
yeah they decided this after a relay
race where one of the female runners
reached back and grabbed what she
thought was a
[Applause]
[Music]
baton at all